[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: December 2018,
astronomers spot strange flares
coming from a galaxy 250
million light years from Earth--
GSN 069.
We know that GSN 069 has a
supermassive black hole in its
center equal to
about half a million
times the mass of the sun.
That's a big black hole.
And it blasts out X-rays
in a very, very steady pace
every nine hours.
Why?
NARRATOR: The flares are
so energetic and regular,
the supermassive
black hole must be
eating the mass of the planet
Mercury three times a day.
The big question is, what's
feeding this black hole
such a huge dinner?
NARRATOR: In March 2020,
scientists found the answer--
an unlucky star at
the end of its life
had wandered into the death
zone of the black hole.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: A
star getting too
close to a
supermassive black hole
is like a glazed donut
getting too close to me--
that thing just is
not going to make it.
PHILIP HOPKINS: Stars that
get too close to a black hole
get torn apart.
They sort of get attacked
by the black hole,
and some of that
material's also getting
launched off in very
powerful winds, and jets,
and streams getting out.
NARRATOR: Somehow
the star survives
its close encounter with
the supermassive black hole.
Further investigation reveals
it's a small compact star,
a white dwarf.
So what makes this tiny
star almost indestructible?
The answer lies in
how it's formed.
AOMAWA SHIELDS: We
get a clue if we look
at the life cycle of a star.
It's burning
hydrogen into helium.
That's causing nuclear
fusion, and that
causes a star to stay stable.
There's this delicate balance
between radiation pressure
from that nuclear
fusion pushing out
and gravitational
pressure pulling in.
But when stars like our sun
near the end of their life,
they run out of hydrogen fuel.
NARRATOR: The sun-like star
makes more and more helium,
which builds up in its center.
Gradually, the immense weight
of the star's outer layers
crushes the helium core.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI:
As the core ages,
it gets smaller and
hotter, which increases
the rate of nuclear reaction.
NARRATOR: These nuclear
fusion reactions
produce more energy, which
pushes the outer layer,
or envelope, outwards.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI:
Because there's more
energy flowing
through the envelope,
the envelope swells up.
NARRATOR: The star
expands to around
100 times its original size.
The yellow star
becomes a red giant.
Eventually, red giants
shed their outer layers,
forming stunning gas shells
called planetary nebulas.
Planetary nebulae are the
most beautiful objects in space.
They're all spectacular.
AMBER STRAUGHN: A star
that ends its life in one
of these planetary nebulas
leaves behind a white dwarf
at the center.
And this white
dwarf is essentially
a cinder, a stellar cinder.
GIBOR BASRI: It's what's
left after nuclear fusion is
no longer possible for
that particular star.
NARRATOR: All that remains--
a glowing white dwarf, the
leftover core of the dead star.
But in galaxy GSN 069,
the supermassive black
hole turbocharged the process.
It stripped off the outer
layers of the red giant
in a matter of days.
PHILIP HOPKINS: The black hole
has almost eaten all the juicy
parts, all the easy-to-get-at
parts of the star,
leaving behind the sort
of bone, or the leftovers
of the white dwarf.
NARRATOR: This
white dwarf is just
a fifth of the mass of the sun.
How can such a
small star survive
being so close to a black hole?
PHIL PLAIT: You might think that
because a white dwarf is small,
it's not going to last very
long because there's not
that much stuff there to eat.
But it turns out it's
quite the opposite.
NARRATOR: The pocket-sized white
dwarf is packed full of matter.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: If it
were a normal star,
it would have been
shredded long ago.
But because it's such a
dense, tight ball of matter,
it survives.
Imagine taking the sun and
crushing it down to just about
the size of the
Earth, same mass,
but now packed way more tightly.
So a basketball
worth of this stuff
would weigh as much
as 35 blue whales.
NARRATOR: The white dwarf's
extreme density protects it
from the gravitational onslaught
of the supermassive black hole.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: Its orbit
takes it near that black hole
every nine hours.
And every time it encounters
the black hole, some
of its material gets sipped off.
They're playing a game
of interstellar tug of war
with one another.
The black hole is bigger,
so it's going to win.
But the white dwarf is very
dense, so it's very tough,
and it's able to hang in
there for quite a long time.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI:
It's going to stay
in orbit around a
supermassive black hole
for billions of years.
Talk about David and Goliath.
NARRATOR: When astronomers
first discovered white dwarfs,
they thought they
shouldn't exist.
How could something have
such an extreme density
and not collapse
under its own weight?
Quantum mechanics, the science
of atomic and subatomic
particles, has the answer.
GIBOR BASRI: We're used
to the rules of physics
up here in the
macroscopic world.
But when you zoom down
into the subatomic world,
things get weird.
Here we have the electron,
one of the tiniest particles
in the universe, and it's
these little electrons
that are doing the work of
supporting an entire star.
Electrons really
don't like being
squashed into a small space.
If you try to squash too many
of them into too small a space,
they'll push back really hard.
And this is an effect
called degeneracy pressure.
NARRATOR: These
degenerate electrons
stop white dwarfs
from collapsing,
but they give these
stars strange qualities.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: White
dwarfs behave very
differently than normal matter.
Take planets and stars--
they become bigger
when they gain mass.
White dwarfs are
the exact opposite.
As they gain mass,
they get smaller.
NARRATOR: The more
massive a white dwarf,
the tighter the electrons
squeeze together
and the smaller and
denser the star gets.
The high density means
the white dwarf's
structure is also strange.
It has an extremely thin
atmosphere made of hydrogen,
or occasionally helium gas.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: If you were
to take an Earth skyscraper
and put it on a
white dwarf star,
if you climb to the
top of that skyscraper,
you'd be outside of the
white dwarf's atmosphere.
You'd actually be in space.
NARRATOR: Beneath
the thin atmosphere
lies a surface of dense
helium around 30 miles thick.
It surrounds an interior made
of superheated liquid carbon
and oxygen.
PHIL PLAIT: A white
dwarf at its surface
can be a half a million degrees.
It's even hotter
in the interior.
And so that kind of material,
it's not going to behave
the way normal matter does.
NARRATOR: Eventually
over billions of years,
the center of the white dwarf
cools down into a solid.
JESSIE CHRISTIANSEN: As
the carbon and oxygen atoms
cool down, they form a crystal.
Diamonds are actually
crystals of carbon.
So at the center of these cool
white dwarfs could be a diamond
the size of the Earth.
NARRATOR: White dwarfs gradually
give off their remaining energy
until there's just a cold,
dead ball of matter--
a black dwarf.
PHILIP HOPKINS: We'd never seen
what we call a black dwarf,
and there's a simple
reason for that.
It takes a tremendous
amount of time, many tens
of billions of years longer
than the age of the universe
to reach that point.
NARRATOR: This is the dark
destiny of most mid-sized
stars, including our sun.
This long, slow death may make
white dwarfs seem ordinary.
But these tiny stars could
answer some big questions
about our universe.
ANDREW PONTZEN: They might be
small, and they might be dim,
but they are essential for
our understanding of physics.
NARRATOR: New research
into white dwarves
may answer one of the
biggest questions of all--
can life survive the
death of its star?
[MUSIC PLAYING]